well this happened about half an hour
ago um we're told by uh local uh
eyewitnesses that some sort of missile
was incoming it appeared to have been
intercepted
but landed the debris landed on this
tram and taxi we understand from the
ambulances that at least one person have
died but someone who we met earlier on
at the previous hit site is uh local mp
alex goncharenko um alex first of all
what do you think has happened here
that's this terror again
this time it is a missile attack you can
see the rest of missile
uh
once again absolutely civilian area like
the first place and
quite close right it's only about three
kilometers away from the residential
apartments yes yes yes probably it is
one battery of things like this i don't
know
and you see that a number of victims
could be much higher because the
place where missile heat is just three
four meters from this building
residential building so three four
meters to the right and all this
building will be destroyed and there are
people inside so these one man killed
men of 1962 year he was born in 1962
yeah although he he was 39
uh yeah 59 sorry and but he was just
just
he was passing that's just accidentally
but four meters to ride
many more people will be killed what do
you make of these tactics and do you
sense that um kiev the capital city is
coming under more and more attacks it
seems to me i mean all i'm hearing this
raid sirens three attacks today the
third was an antonov factory as i know
uh there are no killed there fortunately
but still we have three killed today uh
modern dolls and wounded and it's just
one morning and i think it's just start
so we need to stop it as soon as we can
we need really to provide ukraine with
the air defense systems aircraft just to
stop this horror i've asked you this
before but why would that make so much
difference because it's people people's
life it's hundreds of people who will be
who will be saved if we will be provided
with the air defense aircrafts just for
our army to help and to defend people
and also that's happened here in kiev if
we will not stop putin tomorrow it will
be worse so
tomorrow it will be riga
and i don't know what will be next
and what do you make of these tactics i
mean we've heard president zielinski
saying there's no way they'll be able to
take
the capital city but um from from us
inside the capital city it certainly
feels they're making
edges and they're coming close they're
trying they're trying to encircle kiev
they are trying but i'm also sure that
they could not take kiev i am sure why
why are you so sure
because i believe in our army and in our
people i know belief is good belief is
good but practically they look like
yes they can destroy it yes but they
cannot take it i am also a member of
civi god we have uh dozens of thousands
of people just in here in civic guard
and if they will penetrate the city we
will make hell here for them so
they could not take care but they can
help you too though it is already hell
for us
we've seen it happening in mariopol and
other parties
do you fear that the same thing could
happen to the capital city yes they're
they want to do the same the question is
only of resources and the kiev is 10
times bigger than mariupol so that means
that it will they will need much more
resources and uh ammunition
and
yes but they want to do the same we've
seen social media posts from a chechen
unit which may or may not be true but
outside on the edges
of kiev that's true i know them
personally i mean you there are chechens
fighting for ukraine like volunteers and
there are chechens collaborates which
are putin's like guards
they are fighting against ukraine uh on
the outskirts i mean in the town
settlers of kiev yes
what are your fears about um the
civilians particularly in this capital
city we've spoken to students to former
bankers to former teachers who are all
now taking up arms and so determined to
defend the city but what what can you do
when
you're faced with missiles landing on a
capital city
people like me i'm civilian person i'm a
member of the parliament but i'm also i
also took my arms in my hands and i'm
sure we can
we can hold our city and we can defend
our city that's every person can do
something and when hundreds of thousands
will do their best
they could not do with us anything they
can kill
many of us probably but they cannot take
us
i understood from some of the uh capital
cities administrative um officials that
if the capital is put under siege
they've got about two weeks worth of
food supplies and we know
that the russian military is targeting
the food supply chain how worried are
you about that yesterday the day before
yesterday i was in bravery where they
attacked just uh food warehouses that's
also that that said these genocide
tactics but fortunately kiev is not
under siege now we are not encircled not
yet there are not yet and i believe it
will not be okay great thank you very
much sir thank you alex um hope to see
you again later so there you are a scene
of um
another scene in a capital city that has
really come under attack this morning
three just this morning
dozens and dozens and dozens of
civilians terrorized but still
remarkably showing a great deal of
resilience